[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC PLAYING]
IRENE BUTTER: Well,
I'm very honored
and glad that you invited me
to come and speak here today.
And I am a Jewish child that
grew up during the Holocaust
in Nazi-occupied Europe.
And I'm going to talk
to you about my journey.
My journey was not voluntary.
It was by command.
And basically, I will
talk about the first 15
years of my life, when
I arrived in America,
and then there'll be a little
bit of it since that time.
So the first thing
I want to do is
show you a map of my journey.
And I hope you can see this.
And I'm going over
this very fast.
I was born in Berlin, Germany.
And I was three years old
when Hitler came to power
and the persecution
of Jews began.
My grandfather owned
a bank in Berlin.
My father was his partner.
And about two years after
Hitler came to power,
the bank was taken away
because Jews were not
allowed to own banks, just
like they weren't allowed
to do or be many other things.
And so my father was unemployed.
And he decided to go to
Amsterdam to try to find work.
And then to move
the family there,
because he hoped that
that would help us
escape the execution of Jews
that began very rapidly.
So when I was seven years old,
my family moved to Amsterdam.
And then, what we
hoped was not going
to happen-- the Nazis invaded
Holland, which as you can see,
is an adjoining
country to Germany.
And the Nazis followed.
And they occupied Holland.
They invaded.
And then after a
few days of battle,
Holland became an
occupied country.
And the persecution
of Jews escalated.
So eventually, it
didn't take very long,
my family was deported to the
first concentration camp, which
is the third point on the map.
And that was Westerbork.
Westerbork was a German
concentration camp in Holland.
It was a transit camp.
And most Jews, Dutch Jews or
Jews who lived in Holland,
were transported to death
camps in Eastern Europe.
So we were first
transported there.
And then after about eight
months in Westerbork,
we were transported to
another concentration camp
in Germany called Bergen-Belsen.
Well, from there we were in
Bergen-Belsen almost one year,
barely surviving.
And then we were included
in a prisoner exchange
from Bergen-Belsen.
And we were elated
that that happened.
But the second night on the
train from Bergen-Belsen
to Switzerland, my father died.
We were so close to freedom,
but he did not make it.
What happened then was that
we arrived in Switzerland.
And from there, I was
transported to a refugee camp
in Algiers in North Africa.
It took another year before I
came to America from Africa,
from North Africa,
from this camp.
And then the rest of the
story you will hear later.
So I am now proceeding.
So the persecution of the
Jews was a horrible regime.
Six million Jews were
murdered during the Holocaust,
and six million other people
were murdered, as well.
And they included gypsies,
Jehovah Witnesses, homosexuals,
and dissidents, and all
kinds of other people.
But the Jews were
the main target.
And because the Jews were the
main target, they were labeled.
They were called
all kinds of names,
like criminals, murderers,
cockroaches, monkeys, pigs--
all of these vermin,
all of these names
were applied to the Jews.
I'm going to show you quickly
some pictures of my family
to see what they looked like.
This is a wedding
picture of my parents.
And this is my
brother and myself.
He was two years
older than I was.
And this is a picture
of my dad with myself.
I adored him.
And here are my grandparents.
I had an idyllic childhood.
It was a very happy family--
loving parents,
loving grandparents.
I lived with my grandparents the
first seven years of my life.
And I don't have a
single negative memory
of my childhood.
Then we left Germany
because of the persecution.
And my father found a job with
the American Express company
in Amsterdam.
And this is the
house where we lived.
And next to it, there's a
picture of Anne Frank's house.
She and I lived in
the same neighborhood.
You can see the architecture
is the same, and both of us
lived on the third
floor of the building.
In Holland, we lived
much more modestly,
because the Nazis did
not allow my family
to take all the
assets with them.
But we had a good life, and
the Dutch were very hospitable.
We were never made fun of
because we were refugees.
My brother and I went
to school right away,
learned the Dutch language.
And the first two years
were rather peaceful
until the invasion and
the Nazis took over.
Here's a school picture.
That's a typical school
picture, about third grade.
And you can see
that Anne and I, we
didn't go to the
same school, but it's
the same kind of
picture with a portrait
in the back and a notebook
and a pen in the hand.
This is a passport picture.
And I'm showing
it because there's
something peculiar about it.
The Nazis decided
that the left ear
had to be exposed in
a passport picture.
And I, to this day,
have not found out
what's so special
about the left ear
so that the picture had to
be like this in the passport.
Many restrictions were
imposed on the Jews
after the occupation
by the Nazis.
And this is just one sign that
shows a park, a public park,
was forbidden for Jews.
Many other restrictions applied.
For example, we couldn't
go to movie houses.
We couldn't go to theaters.
We couldn't go to parks.
As you can see, not
to swimming pools--
many public places
were forbidden.
In addition to that,
we had curfews.
We had to be home at
8 o'clock every night.
We Jews could not go to food
stores until after 3 o'clock
in the afternoon.
And it was wartime.
There were many scarcities.
So often there wasn't any
food left after 3 o'clock
in the afternoon.
Then we had to wear the Star
of David on our clothing
all the time.
So everybody could
see you were a Jew.
There was no difficulty
distinguishing.
And then came the deportation.
And this shows a picture of
the method used by the Nazis
to deport Jews from their homes.
What they would do is
they would block off
an entire neighborhood.
And with their
loudspeakers, they
would chase everybody
into their houses.
Nobody was allowed
on the street.
And then they would go from
house to house and from
door to door and look for Jews.
And if they found Jews, they
gave you 10 minutes to pack,
and then you had to leave.
And here on the picture you
can see all these people
with their bundles, their
suitcases, baby carriages.
Young or old were just
marched out of their homes
to a big square.
And there we waited until
they came with trucks.
They loaded us on trucks and
took us to the railway station.
And at the railway
station, there
was this long, long train.
But it wasn't a passenger train.
It was this kind of a
train, a cattle car train,
that they transported
Jews to the camps.
And so they loaded, like, 50,
60, 70 people into one wagon.
And then they closed it.
There was no water.
There was no toilet.
There was no food.
And there was no air.
Because when they closed
the doors, no windows.
And it was very
uncomfortable, very crowded.
Some people didn't even
find a place to sit down.
They had to sit on
somebody else's lap.
And then you'd be locked up.
Many people, as they were
transported to Eastern Europe
to a death camp, spent days
in a cattle car like this.
In our case, we were in
this car about eight hours.
And then we arrived
in Camp Westerbork.
And this is what it looked like.
You see the barracks
on the left side.
And on the right side, you see
the kind of beds we slept in.
They were bunk beds,
steel framed, three tiers.
And all they had was a
straw mattress, no blankets,
no pillows, nothing like that.
And this was Camp Westerbork.
120,000 Jews were
deported from Westerbork
to other concentration camps.
Life there was not
pleasant, of course.
Adults had to go to
work, all kinds of work.
I was only 12 years old.
So I didn't go to work.
My brother had a
job as a messenger.
He had a bicycle.
And he would take messages
from one place to another.
For kids like me, it
was absolute boredom.
There was nothing to do.
There was no school, no
playground, no library,
no books, no toys, no nothing.
It was complete boredom.
The most traumatic memory
I have of this camp
is that every week a
train came, a cattle car
train, on Saturday afternoon.
The camp was divided
by a railroad track.
So wherever you
went in the camp,
you had to cross
the railroad track.
And this train, this cattle car
train, pulled in on Saturday
afternoon.
And it would sit there
the rest of Saturday,
all day Sunday,
and all day Monday.
And then Monday night,
all the barrack leaders
would turn on the
lights and they
would read off a list
of names of the people
who had to go on the train.
And they always went
to a death camp.
So you lived in continuous fear.
Because on Tuesday morning,
the train had to leave.
First you woke up and you
listened whether your name
was on the list.
And if you were lucky that
it wasn't on the list, then
usually what we would do is
we would go to other barracks
where we had friends
or family, and we
would see who had to leave
on that train that night,
and spend the rest of
the night together.
And then the morning would come,
and we'd have to say goodbye.
And we pretty much knew
that it was not likely
that we would ever
see each other again.
And then the train left.
But next Saturday, it
would show up again.
So this was a cycle,
a weekly cycle.
The train would come, and this
ominous train would sit there,
and then it would leave.
And then a week later,
it was right back.
And so that was the
most difficult part
of living in Westerbork.
Now, before we were
arrested, my father
met a friend who had
just received passports
from Ecuador.
And people thought
that maybe, if you
had a passport for a foreign
country, an Allied country,
then maybe you
could escape death.
And so my father wrote
away for these passports.
And one day in Westerbork,
we received a package.
And we opened the package.
And it contained four
Ecuadorian passports.
And that was, in
a way, a miracle.
Because my father had sent
away for the passports.
They did not arrive
before we were deported.
And all of a sudden
this package appeared.
And we never got any mail
forwarded to us to the camp.
So in a sense, it was a miracle.
And it changed our status
in Westerbork immediately.
Because we were no
longer just Jews.
We were now exchange Jews.
And that meant that--
it related to the fact that
the Germans, the Nazis,
had a foreign policy.
And this policy was called
the exchange policy, [GERMAN]..
And that the Jews that
had these passports
were not going to be
sent to any death camp.
We were no longer
at risk of being
sent to Auschwitz on
one of those trains that
showed up every Saturday.
And so a few months
later, we were
sent to Bergen-Belsen,
the next camp.
And we were told when we left
Westerbork that Bergen-Belsen
would be a better camp.
And besides, we would
not be there very long,
because we would be exchanged.
We would be part of a
prisoner exchange whereby
the Germans would exchange us,
either for German prisoners
of war, or for
German citizens who
were living in Allied
countries and they
couldn't come back to Germany.
Because during wartime
the borders closed,
and you can't travel.
You can't move.
And so we came to Bergen-Belsen.
And you see here the picture
on top has the barracks.
They were not very different
from barracks in Westerbork.
But then that lower picture,
it shows barbed wire.
And there are people behind it.
And they're wearing rags,
they're very skinny,
and they have these fearful
expressions on their faces.
And it looked ominous.
It showed us that this was
not going to be a better
camp than Westerbork was.
Now, Bergen-Belsen
was really a horrible,
a brutal, a cruel camp.
The adults had to do slave
labor from early morning
till night, six and
a half days a week.
And if there was punishment
for one reason or another, then
maybe they had to work that last
half day of the week, as well.
We had to stand on a big
square to be counted.
There was roll call at
least one time a day,
but sometimes
several times a day.
Standing in the
cold or in the heat
or in the rain, standing in
place, in columns of five,
you couldn't sit.
You couldn't jump.
You couldn't talk to anybody.
It was a form of
torture to be counted
on this square every single day.
The food rations were minimal.
We received a piece of bread
about three inches wide.
And at night, there was a
soup, and most of the time,
it consisted of turnips
being boiled in water.
It was not a food ration
that people could survive on.
People became malnourished.
And there were diseases.
The hygienic conditions
were terrible.
There was only cold
water, no soap.
The bathrooms were filthy.
And all of us had lice.
And lice transmit diseases.
So there were epidemics.
There was cholera.
There was typhus.
There was polio, pneumonia,
dysentery, all these diseases
that spread rampantly.
And people were
sick all the time.
And people were dying.
In addition to that,
there was torture.
People were beaten up brutally.
And the death rate
was extremely high.
So we were waiting for exchange.
But this exchange, this prisoner
exchange just didn't come.
There is an aerial
picture on the left,
which is the roll call
square where we were counted.
You can't see it very well.
But that's where we were rounded
up every day, at least once.
And now on the
lower picture, you
see the kind of
beds we slept in.
And as the camp became
more and more crowded,
two people had to share a bed.
It was a narrow bed.
And of course, with the
lice and the disease,
diseases spread even more
quickly, being so congested.
So life was pretty intolerable.
Now, one day, there
was an announcement
that people who had a passport,
a South American or a Central
American passport, had to line
up and be screened by a doctor
for leaving the camp.
And it was really a miracle
that my family was included,
because my mother had taken ill.
And she'd been bedridden
for several months.
I was taking care of her.
And my father, that day when
we had to report to the doctor,
came back from labor.
And he seemed very sick, and
he was partly not conscious.
And we found out later that
he had been very badly beaten
that day.
But anyway, finally-- first my
brother and I went to report.
We tried to get my
mother to walk there.
But she collapsed.
We had to take her
back to the barrack.
And then, in the
end, my father went.
And so when I went
with my father,
the doctor looked at him, and
he said, are you John Hasenberg?
And then he said, are you sick?
And my father said, no, which
was a ridiculous question.
And then he looked
at me, and he said,
your children have
already been here.
He checked off my mother's
name, looking at me.
And he said, tomorrow, you
will be leaving the camp
for the prisoner exchange.
And we will never
know whether he
was being kind to
include our family,
or whether I and my mother
looked the same here.
I was a 14-year-old child.
And my mother in her 40s.
But anyway, we made it to the
train leaving Bergen-Belsen,
leaving that hell that day.
And of course, we were elated.
We got warm food.
The train was heated.
It wasn't a cattle car train.
It was a passenger train.
And here's a picture
a student drew.
It was a Red Cross train.
And when we saw the Red Cross,
we thought, well, maybe there's
hope here.
So the train started moving.
And the second night on the
train, my father passed away.
And he had done everything
possible to save his family.
But he just-- and we
were so close to freedom.
But he could not make it.
And so my mother,
my brother, and I
had no choice but to
continue the journey.
His remains were taken off the
train in a small southern town
in Germany.
And we went, we continued.
And two days later, we
arrived in Switzerland.
My mother was dying, and my
brother had another illness.
And so they were
taken off the train
and hospitalized immediately.
I was not allowed to stay there.
I wasn't sick enough
to be hospitalized.
And the Swiss were totally
averse to keeping any more
refugees.
So I was sent on, with a
group of 100 or so people,
to a camp in North Africa,
in Algiers, a refugee camp.
The war was over.
[INAUDIBLE]
The war had been ended.
And we were what was
called displaced persons.
We were displaced from
our home in Germany.
We were displaced from Holland.
And that's what people were
called after the Holocaust,
displaced persons.
And most of them were housed
in displaced persons camps.
Now, this is the
camp in North Africa.
You see the barracks
we lived in.
And it's the only
two pictures I have--
the one with a group
of young people
that we hang out together.
Now, in North Africa, certainly
life was considerably better
than Bergen-Belsen.
But here I was, 14
years old, my father
had just died a few days ago.
And I was separated from
my mother and brother.
And we were separated,
not just different cities
or different countries, we were
on two different continents.
For several months,
the war had not ended.
I didn't have any
contact with my family.
I didn't know if
they were surviving.
And after a while, I got
a telegram telling me
that they were recovering.
Now, nothing was done to
reunite me with my family.
I wasn't allowed to go back to
Switzerland to be with them.
And they never came
to North Africa.
We finally were
reunited in America.
It took one year before I was
able to come to the United
States.
And it took my mother and
brother six more months.
And so we were separated
for one and a half years.
And so when I hear
what is happening
at the border of this country
these days, where children
are being taken away
from their families,
my heart really weeps.
Because I have never
forgotten the trauma
of that period of being alone.
Now, when I came
to America, we had
to wait a long time
for transportation.
The war was over.
And so the way in which
we came to America
was on a Liberty Ship.
Now, Liberty Ships were built
during the war in 24 hours,
mostly to transport cargo to
support the troops in Europe.
And it was a very rough ocean.
It was three weeks in December.
And so I was on this ship
with a few other people,
because they weren't
built for passengers.
And one day, an American
doctor who was part of the crew
told this story about
the Liberty Ships.
He said sometimes
they break in half.
And so I became very scared.
And he said the part of the ship
that will make it to America
is the part that has the engine.
And so I kept looking
for the engine,
because I wanted to be
sure that I would arrive.
Later on, people told
me it was a joke.
But here you see a picture of
a Liberty Ship breaking in half
in the middle of the ocean.
Anyway, we arrived.
I lived with cousins
of my mother.
Went to school immediately,
because I hadn't had
any schooling for three years--
even more than three years.
And this is the graduation
picture from high school.
Then I went to a tuition-free
college in New York City.
Can you imagine a
tuition-free college today?
And I worked in the summer.
And here I'm at a summer
resort in upstate New York,
being a waitress.
So that's how it was
able to earn money
during the summertime.
And after graduating
from college,
I went to Duke University
and got a PhD in economics,
met my husband, and so we both
got our PhDs at Duke University
before we came to the
University of Michigan,
where we spent more than 35
years on the faculty, both
of us.
Here are my kids.
They're in their 50s now.
On the left side are
my two granddaughters,
they're my daughter's daughters.
And then on the right
is my son's boy.
He's the youngest
one of the crew.
And five months ago, I
became a great-grandmother.
And so the baby has to be
added to the PowerPoint.
[APPLAUSE]
And so here I'm
teaching economics
at the University of Michigan.
This is a picture
during the 1970s.
It's graduation day.
You see all the guys in
front are wearing suits
and white shirts and ties.
And then behind
them is the faculty.
And they're wearing suits
and white shirts and ties.
And that's how people dressed
for graduation in those days.
And then over on the
right, that's me.
And so if you saw the
same picture today,
there would be at least 50% of
the students would be women,
and probably close to 50% of
the faculty would also be women.
So sometimes things
change for the better.
And so my brother
has two children.
And I have two.
And one day, at
a family reunion,
our kids demanded
that we take them
back on a journey to the
sites of family history.
So we went to Berlin, to
Amsterdam, to Westerbork.
And this is Bergen-Belsen.
We were visiting there.
And that's just-- the camp
existed from '40 to '45,
and then became a
displaced persons camp.
And this is a sign at the entry.
And here you see a mass grave.
Because when the Allies came
to liberate Bergen-Belsen,
they found so many dead bodies.
They didn't know
what to do with them.
And they had to bury
them in mass graves.
Here is a sign for Anne Frank,
Anne Frank and her sister,
Margot, that was put up later.
And we visited my father's
grave at a Jewish cemetery
in southern Germany.
And so my peace work--
I helped found the Wallenberg
Medal and Lecture Series.
Raoul Wallenberg was a Swede.
He was a student at the
University of Michigan
from '31 to '35.
And he saved tens of
thousands of Jews in Budapest.
And so this is a way of
honoring him every year.
If you ever want to hear
a wonderful lecture,
then look for the Wallenberg
lectures every fall.
And it's a humanitarian.
Here's the Dalai Lama.
He's one of the
Wallenberg medalists.
And here are a bunch of others.
And now we're up to the
27th Wallenberg Lecture.
And this is a
group I co-founded,
consisting of six Palestinian
and six Jewish women.
And our motto is
"refusing to be enemies."
We have existed for,
I think, 16 years.
We meet every other week
in our homes to do dialogue
on complicated issues.
And when we are
invited, we give talks
about refusing to be
enemies and how much we
can learn from each other if
we are open to meet people
from other cultures, other
religions, other nations
and do dialogue, which is a
form of communication that
is very liberating
and very educational.
We learn a lot from each other.
And this is my book.
It's my memoir.
I published it last year.
And it has the first
15 years of my life
with a lot more detail of the
story that I've just told you.
So I will stop here.
I have a few books, if
anybody didn't get one before.
And I look forward to
a lot of questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for coming here.
I was just curious.
You had mentioned
that, at the camp,
they had called out for folks
with South American passports.
And I saw in your slide that
you had an Ecuadorian passport.
And I wondered how
you came across--
how you came to obtain a
South American passport.
IRENE BUTTER: My father wrote to
a man in Sweden, in Stockholm.
And he managed to get them from
a consul, an Ecuadorian consul.
All over Europe, there were
consulates from those countries
that issued passports
because they
knew of this exchange policy.
So many, many people
had passports.
But very few ever got exchanged.
And the passport--
this is interesting--
was issued under the
following two conditions.
One was that we
would never apply
for a visa to come to Ecuador.
And that after the war, we
had to turn in the passport.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much
for sharing your story.
I just wondered what
happened to your mother,
if you were ever
reunited with her.
IRENE BUTTER: Yes.
My mother and my brother
came to America six months
after I arrived here.
And she was very traumatized
for most of her life,
but she adapted.
It was difficult here.
She had never worked before.
She found herself the
mother of two teenage kids,
a single parent.
She had to do minimum wage
labor to support our family.
But she had a
relatively good life.
And she lived till age 86.
AUDIENCE: How was it for you
navigating your Jewish heritage
after leaving the concentration
camps and making it to America?
Did you find yourself steering
away from your history,
or did you embrace it even more
after all you went through?
IRENE BUTTER: Well, that's
a very good question.
I certainly did not
turn away from it.
We had family in America.
And the early years
after the war,
there were other survivors
in New York, kids
that I became friends
with in Algiers.
And so most of our
social life was really
with other survivors.
But I never abandoned
my Jewish heritage.
But I didn't limit
myself to that, either.
AUDIENCE: How have you managed
not to be angry all the time
about what's happened
to you in your life?
How do you deal with
that, psychologically?
IRENE BUTTER: That's
a good question, too.
Well, you know,
anger eats you up.
Anger is very destructive.
It doesn't really help anybody.
I mean, I wasn't near the Nazis.
Probably if I had met them
shortly after the war,
I would have been angry.
But I was lucky to come
to America, far removed
from everything.
And I think it's
important to forgive.
Because for one,
forgiveness is healing.
And I think you can do
more about all the evil
and the destruction
that took place
if you work on forgiveness.
Now, I have my three
conditions for forgiveness.
I think people who
participated in mass murder,
they have to admit what
they did, first of all.
They have to show remorse.
And preferably they show
that they have done something
to go beyond that, something to
make the world a better place.
I wouldn't forgive
people who don't admit
or who defend what they did
as having been the right thing
to do.
AUDIENCE: What was it
like to go back to Germany
with your family and go kind
of back to your [INAUDIBLE]
but also back to
a place that was
a really-- probably the most
traumatic time in your past?
IRENE BUTTER: Thank
you for that question.
First when our children
asked us, we were shocked.
We never thought we would go
back to any of those places.
But then we thought we
should, since they wanted it.
And it's complicated.
It was, on the one
hand, very painful,
especially to go back
to Bergen-Belsen.
But on the other hand, it was
such an amazing experience
for us to share.
And when we came
to Bergen-Belsen,
the feeling of
taking your children
to the place where you
were supposed to be killed
was really a
liberating experience.
So I think in the
end, even though there
were many painful moments,
we were all glad we did it.
And the sharing with our
children was just amazing.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
Thank you again for your story.
My question was,
was there a moment
after you came to America
where you realized
that you had this story to
share and how you kind of got
the voice to share
your experiences
outside your family?
IRENE BUTTER: Well, that's
a really important question.
When I arrived in New
York and my relatives
took-- they picked me up
at Grand Central Station.
We went on the
subway to the Bronx,
where they lived, and
got to their apartment.
And they said this.
They said, now you're
here in America, finally.
You have to start a new life.
You have to forget about the
past and never speak about it.
And this is a message that many
survivors received when they
first came to this country--
never talk about it.
If we mentioned it at all, we
would be silenced immediately.
And so this led to four
decades of silence,
where even my mother,
my brother, and I rarely
talked about it, and
certainly not in any depth.
And then in the '80s,
things started happening.
Elie Wiesel, who was the leading
spokesperson for the victims
and survivors of the Holocaust,
I heard him speak once.
And this is what he said.
He said, if you were at the
camps, if you smelled the air
and heard the
silence of the dead,
it is your duty to be a
witness, to provide testimony,
to tell the story.
And that made a deep
impression on me.
And then in the late '80s, there
was an Anne Frank exhibition.
It traveled all
over the country.
It ended up in Detroit.
And I was invited
to speak on a panel.
And I was trying to
decide what would I say.
And I just became aware that
this was all about Anne Frank.
Anne Frank wasn't here
to tell her story.
Her voice was silenced forever.
And I was given
the gift of life.
So it is my duty to
tell the stories.
And then I started
talking in schools.
And I've been talking
more than 35 years now.
And I haven't shut up.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Can you talk
about your time in school
as probably one of the
only females in your class?
And maybe what you went
through, and was it positive?
Was it negative?
Did people receive
you well as a female?
IRENE BUTTER: Well, I went to
graduate school in the '50s.
And people treated me very well.
I wasn't aware of any
form of discrimination.
But you know, it was the '50s.
And we weren't as aware
of discrimination.
So one day, we had
a group like you,
maybe, a group of students
who had a little money.
We could invite economists to
come and speak to us, you know?
And I was always making
the hors d'oeuvres.
And one of my professors
one day said, maybe
this should be your career.
And I didn't consider it as
being a discriminatory comment.
But maybe it was.
Maybe he was giving
me a message I didn't
belong in economics, right?
But in general, I did not
experience discrimination,
not here--
well, here at the
University, it's interesting.
When we came in the '60s, there
was a nepotism law on campus.
And that meant that husband and
wife could not receive tenure
if we were in the same college.
And my husband
was in psychology,
and I was in economics.
And that's in the same college
in literature, science,
and arts.
So I would not have
been able to get tenure.
And that's how I transferred
to public health.
But that law is long gone.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
again for speaking.
As a mother of a
seven-year-old myself,
it really touched me when you
were talking about being seven
and starting this journey.
And what I struggle
with every day
is seeing sometimes the anger
and intolerance that we even
see in our own country today.
What advice do you
have to parents
to be able to help our
children deal with this
and help our children make
the world a better place,
despite what they may be
seeing and experiencing?
IRENE BUTTER: Well, it's
interesting you ask this.
Because these things are
not taught in school,
which is very unfortunate.
And I think parents can
be models for their kids.
And you know, my theme
is, never a bystander.
When you see bullying,
when you see injustice,
you see mistreatment,
you can't turn your back.
You need to do something.
You need to interrupt
or intervene.
And I think if parents model
that, then children will learn.
But they're not going to get
it in school, most likely.
And this morning,
there was a program
on "1A," Joshua Johnson,
about whether schools
teach about the environment, the
destruction of the environment.
And very few schools
teach that subject.
And you know, that's
another example,
things that are so
crucial to learn
are not included
in the curriculum.
So whatever you can do about
the school that your kids go to,
and whatever you can do
to model the right thing.
I think "do an act of kindness"
should be the motto every day.
If you do it every day, it could
be just a tiny little thing,
then it becomes a habit.
And then you can move on to
other kinds of behaviors.
But I think it's very
frightening what's
happening now, all the
hatred and all the bigotry
and discrimination we see and
deportation of certain groups.
We need to be change-makers.
We need to be active.
And one kind of behavior that's
definitely very important
is voting.
Young people don't have
a good voting record.
And they need to
become more involved.
I mean, voting is one of the
privileges in a democracy.
You can make a difference.
Every person can
make a difference.
And just to become more
aware of what's going on
and what we can do is
definitely a high priority.
AUDIENCE: I would
love to know what
inspired you to form the
group of Jewish and Arab women
to have open dialogue
with each other.
IRENE BUTTER:
Well, first of all,
my daughter, when she
graduated from high school,
she left home and
went to Israel,
she said to find
her Jewish identity.
And she married a Palestinian.
So I became familiar
with another culture,
with Palestinians.
And whenever I
went over there, I
saw the divide between Jewish
and Palestinian people.
And it concerned me because
I have two granddaughters who
have a double identity.
And I wanted to work for a world
where they would be recognized
as equals by both peoples.
So things got worse and
worse in the Middle East.
And at one point, I had some
friends, Jewish friends,
who had kids there.
And then started the intifadas
and all the uprisings.
And we were concerned about
our families over there.
So that's how we
started doing this.
Six of the 12 women are still
there from the original group.
And others have moved
away, and things happened.
But we try to work for peace.
But there isn't much we can
do at this point except model
our friendships and our
connections and give talks.
And we go to churches and
schools and university classes.
And everybody can do
this with any two groups.
And once you try, you
find out how satisfying
it is to cross the divide
and learn from each other
and be open to
cultural differences.
And when you do
that, you find out
that the differences are
far smaller than what we all
have in common.
So I definitely recommend it.
AUDIENCE: I'm
curious what got you
through some of the most
difficult times in your life,
back in the camps?
Do you attribute
that to your faith?
Was it love of your family?
Was it the promise of
freedom at some point?
What got you through
those periods of hell?
IRENE BUTTER: Well, in a way,
it's a non-answerable question.
But I really wanted to live.
And I think you have
to have a purpose when
you're living under those
circumstances, where each--
the next day is always
worse than the previous day.
And I saw my parents' health
deteriorating so rapidly.
So I was taking care of them
and that had to keep me going.
I had to be there to do
whatever I could for them.
And I also had a dream.
Well, I had several dreams.
One was to be a dog
under the dinner
table in the home
of a wealthy family.
That was one dream.
And my other dream was that
when I was a little girl,
I read books about Heidi.
I don't know if people
still read Heidi books.
And Heidi was an
orphan and she went
to live with her grandfather in
Switzerland in the mountains.
And she did a lot of skiing.
And I wanted to survive so
I could go to Switzerland
and learn how to ski.
I never did.
[LAUGHTER]
But it kept me going.
SPEAKER 1: With that, we are
going to complete this session.
Irene, a huge, huge
thank you on behalf
of Google Ann Arbor for coming
and sharing your story here
today with us.
IRENE BUTTER: Thank you.
Thank you all for coming.
[APPLAUSE]